I have to ask you a
deep and important question you often
when we text back and forth send me two
hugging emojis
uh can we psychoanalyze the reason why
that's your favorite emoji
of the hugging face is that it's it's
like it's kind of like sending a heart
but a little bit more yeah it's uh
gender neutral
when Jujitsu players uh meet each other
they often shake hands and then give a
quick hug so I thought it was the most
appropriate Emoji for Judas who players
I see so so you're a pretty simple
explanation nothing too Freudian there
are you sure
quite sure okay have you really asked
yourself deeply because you're really
lean on an emojis there's something
behind it tomorrow I'm never getting why
is that emoji again
walk away I'll shock you tomorrow and
hit you with three
three it's almost always two
I think maybe your creature of habit in
communication there's a I'm a creature
of Heaven in almost every aspect of my
life so even emojis
yeah you fall into these little pockets
of how you communicate how you show
affection towards others I send I say
love a lot I sent I send hearts and
don't give a [ __ ] if it's too like
you know like in a you know me sending a
message to like a CEO I'm about to
interview I'll send a heart I don't give
a damn
they'll probably just like look uh what
is this but uh I think people are
to
afraid of simple
communication of affection
like uh it could be in any form but
there's a hesitance to that because I
think underneath it in order to show
affection
you're taking a risk and you're showing
vulnerability
because if you show affection and the
other person rejects that affection
you've now placed yourself in a
hierarchies going back to Lions of like
oh this person you're just like the
silly weak person and they're the strong
person I think that's called you might
see it I guess but I I don't to me the
display of vulnerability is a display of
strength
not not weakness at least in human
society at least at this time